هذه صور الغار التي نفذها سلاح الجو
التركي في شمال سوريا قبل استهداف في
مناطق المقاتلين الاكراد نشرت وزاره
الدفاع التركيه صوره المقاتله اثناء
اقلاعها واعلنت ان الساعه الحساب قد دقت
حساب الاكراد المسؤولين عن التفجير وفق
انقره الذي وقع في اسطنبول الاسبوع الماضي
واسفار عن مقتل واصابه 10
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اتهمت انقره
بالنازحين داخليا من عفرين اما قائدها
العام الذي اكد منذ بضعه ايام ان لا علاقه
لقوته بتفجير اسطنبول وصف الغاره الجويه
ولكن ان صارت الحرب سيتاثر الجميع
ضد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي تصنف
بالارهابيه لكنها لم تحصل وفقا محللين على
الضوء الاخضر من ايران وروسيا اعتقال
الشرطه البلغاريه لخمسه اشخاص يجتمع
بطوطهم بتفجير اسطنبول دفعها الى تنفيذ
هذا الغاره خاصه وانه من بين المجتبهي بهم
رجل وامراه ينحذران من اصل كرديا سوري